so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't want to hear any more of these
lies
about reckless spending
we're changing people's lives
what up yo i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report it is june 15th 2022 and
that was the elderly man pretending to
be president giving a speech where he
emoted and i have no doubt that on the
teleprompter it said emote
scream as you're saying this and he is
changing people's lives i like to give
credit where credit is due he is
changing lives that is factually true
the fact checkers can check it it's just
not that he's changing him for the
better most things not going well and
the machine
is turning on old joe and there is
incredible
not only opportunity right now but there
is stuff literally happening this second
including an election that happened in
texas just yesterday
showing that the worm is turning and we
are gonna win people and i mean that
politically
spiritually economically
culturally
the whole freaking thing and that's what
today's show is all about uh quick
reminder if you'd like to see me in
miami next month july 14th i'm at the
miami improv we just added a bunch more
vip tickets because they sold out
basically overnight you can go to
davereuben.com
events
and uh all right let's get to the show
so first off uh i know not you but there
are people out there
who are most likely sitting with their
coffee
sitting on the couch with their feet up
watching the view right now and the view
is a program with five or seven or
twelve or four it's unclear to me how
many hosts they still have uh women who
are supposed to be there to talk about
issues calmly and respectfully and share
their
views
and do it in a way that would enlighten
people and it was mostly designed really
for housewives that were home during the
day when it started 20 25 years ago
when barbara walters had the idea but
it's become into it's turned into just
like a complete [ __ ] show it is just an
endless disaster where they bash on
conservatives they lie about everything
going on you've got a racist woman and
an alcoholic and a lunatic and it's just
completely completely insane but finally
because i keep saying to you guys that
finally there's always this airlock with
mainstream media so a bunch of us online
we can talk about things for a while we
can talk about hunter biden's laptop or
we can talk about the lab leak from
china or we can talk about the fact that
joe biden is obviously mentally unfit to
be president we can talk about these
things for years online but there's this
weird airlock
that goes on in corporate press in
mainstream media that suddenly they
start talking about it for like a day or
two and then it bursts forth and what's
happening right now it's happening in
real time right now the meme the idea
of joe biden being unfit which we all
obviously know he literally cannot
complete a sentence it is rare that he
can complete one single sentence he has
trouble reading off the teleprompter he
slurs through all these sentences he
makes up words he loses people's names
all of these things and that's not again
i'm going to stop saying this because
it's not worth saying every time it's
not to make fun of or mock anyone that
has dementia or any other degenerative
degenerative disease obviously it's not
to do that but the guy is supposed to be
in charge of the united states of
america he's supposed to be the leader
of the free world well anyway these
things are starting to leak into the
mainstream media because they can't hide
it anymore we can all see it uh so they
started talking about it on the view
finally in the last couple days uh we're
gonna throw a clip right now the woman
that you're gonna see first i believe is
alison farah she's a conservative
supposedly a conservative
and she's i guess guest hosting because
they can't get a regular conservative to
take the gig no matter how many millions
they offer for that gig after megan
mccain left and elizabeth elizabeth
hasselbeck before her they can't get
anyone to take the gig because who would
want to be just basically gang raped by
sonny hostin and joy behar and whoopi
goldberg every week anyway allison
farris she's a conservative here she is
uh talking about what's going on with
joe
i think sorry to jump in but i think
anyone looking at their retirement
account yesterday looking at fuel prices
looking at inflation not all of which by
the way are biden's fault that creates a
path and a window for a donald trump to
come back and in a kind of asking the
question of who is best fit to beat
donald trump because that man should
never be president again i'm not sure i
think it's joe biden and the fact that
david axelrod senior obama and biden
adviser came out and said you know he's
going to be 82. it's not about age i
don't think he has the same strength and
sharpness i saw five years ago with
biden and i have tremendous respect for
the man so i'm curious like who are the
dems gonna run where's the like obama
energy that we could bring you know i
don't know if we need obama energy we
need somebody who can
get the country back on
on
line in line yeah because it said you
know it it if you can name me
a republican who has a shot yeah to do
that that's what i'm more interested in
because i think it'll just sanchez i
hope it's not death santa's over in
florida because i think he's a fascist
death santa's i think i think he handled
kova miserably i think he's a fascist
and a bigot but i uh those are good
points those are his good points
joy
18 writers
okay so let's uh knock out the allison
farris though first so you know she
starts of course they bring on a
conservative who's completely anti-trump
right he can't be president again it
can't be trump again i'm not even saying
it should be trump
as i keep saying on the show and i'm
going to keep talking about and perhaps
i'm a little bit uniquely positioned to
talk about as a new floridian and
someone that has a little bit of
relationship with these two guys like
the trump desantis thing has to be
worked out right
just let's just put that out there that
thing has to be worked out and i think
they will work it out the media is going
to try to make it seem like they hate
each other and they're trying to destroy
each other i don't think there's any
evidence of that we will see about that
but first allison farah she's the
conservative first the guy who most
likely is the nominee that guy can't run
of course then did you catch the line
there she goes uh she goes we
need someone with the obama energy we
meaning she's obviously not a
conservative or she's not a republican
but you know okay so fine this is just
the theatrics of television they bring
on these people they fake the fact that
the idea that they're a conservative but
we need someone with the energy now okay
fine whatever the interesting thing a
couple interesting things happened there
did you note that whoopi who years ago
whoopi was a perfectly sane person when
she started on the view i would say she
was an old school
lib you know trump broke her covet broke
her okay she implied
that she would be willing to vote for a
republican if there was someone who
could get the country back online or in
line now i don't know exactly what she
means by that but in essence what she's
saying is things are screwy
things are screwy and if someone could
come out there and fix things that would
be good now obviously
obviously the person that can do that
and the person who's been doing it most
effectively and who i think you could
argue at some level already is the
president of the united states not by
title but by the very nature of their
work is ron desantis right he is
modeling what a free america what a free
state thus a free america can look like
so would whoopi dare do it would whoopi
come out and support iran desantis that
would be interesting would bill maher
who's always talking about how great
things are in florida although he always
says but i would never go to florida
would he would any of these liberals
would they support desantis and then of
course
sonny hostin who must be she might be
and this is a this is a bold statement
she might be the most
uh unpleasant person
on television her body language her
dismissiveness the way she looks at the
guests everything about her death santis
that's so clever i mean florida's rates
of covet and death were actually better
than california florida state open
florida is flourishing we didn't destroy
our economy crime and the rest of it
didn't run rampant florida also has the
second oldest population in the united
states so you'd think that all sorts of
people would be dropping dead left and
right uh so
death santas okay that's very clever and
joy you know okay that's clever that's
clever uh she also calls him a fascist i
don't think she understands what a
fascist is ron desantis is actually the
complete reverse of a fascist because he
is trying to get the government out of
people's lives but she's just a dullard
and a [ __ ] but the reason i wanted to
show you this is i think you can start
to see the move the media is going to
make whether it is trump or whether it
is desantis or whether any of that even
matters and desantis has to win his own
race here and everything else they are
going to treat desantis as trump and
desantis has been training
he has been watching and dealing with
the florida media the national media
calling him a fascist dealing with all
of that nonsense and he has been
punching back taking the hits fighting
continuing to win continuing to get his
agenda done and everything else but you
just watch if you thought oh they were
just treating trump a certain way
because trump grabbed him by the [ __ ]
and trump is orange and trump this that
and the other thing it's like watch what
they will do to anyone else and the
reason that the media hated trump so
much is trump fought back but i think
desantis has actually learned a matrix
style oh i know what is he what does he
say in matrix neo oh i know
i know jujitsu is that the line i know
karate or jiu jitsu now yeah i think
that's what desantis basically has been
doing but all of this leads to that
biden what this is really about
is that really people realize biden is a
disaster they realize nobody likes
kamala that this thing is falling apart
fast so the ladies of the view continue
and they hypothesize about what
democrats should run in 2024
i hate this talk about
i think people
saying that he's too old i mean you know
if the former you know twice
impeached disgraced president thinks he
he's such a young spring chicken i mean
he's going to be 78 uh when when joe
biden is 81 and so i don't like this
ageism argument but i will say
when he was here i asked him he works
out every day yeah i don't think trump
does take a look yeah i mean take a look
exactly yeah but but i do think there
are plenty of you know um democrats that
that have uh tons of verve and energy i
mean i like gavin newsom because he's
really pretty to look at and i think he
does a great job in california um i like
kamala uh kamala and pete boudija i love
tickets i think that looks great do you
think they could win really well i would
vote for them i hope this country is
ready for something like that um i think
the brain power alone would would just
uh obliterate trump or and i would just
love to
it's not just
that sonny hassan is the most unpleasant
person really the most deeply unpleasant
person
on television and that's a quite a
statement i mean she sits usually on a
panel with anna navarro i mean these are
deeply unpleasant you know judgmental
really just the awful
that that thing that that so many people
now think about liberals this sort of
elite smug
unpleasant
awfulness right
it's not just that she's that she's also
an idiot i mean she's just an idiot now
first off
gavin newsom
gavin newsom gavin newsom has almost
single-handedly destroyed
california and now i will put more money
in the jar gavin newsom has caused
california for the first time in the
history of california
to lose
uh population for the last two years for
the first time ever okay
almost 300 000 people have fled
california
its main cities san francisco los
angeles are dystopian nightmares crime
is rampant homeless this is rampant okay
you know all of that so she likes what
he's done and he's pretty to look at yes
he does have slick hair i'll give him
that there there i finally could say
something nice about avenues i don't
even like his hair i'm just saying he
has slick pat riley-esque
you know 1987 lakers hair okay fine uh
so she goes on about that and then who
does she want to run well she likes pete
and kamala now kamala is an airhead
kamala what do we know about kamala what
does kamala know kamala know that russia
big ukraine small that is the extent
of the brain power as she calls it and
pete pete buddhich and what do we know
about pete pete is gay pete is gay and
that's why he got the job so you have a
woman who knows that russia is big and
pete who is gay these people are not
professionals we also know that pete
went on two months paternity leave when
his kids were born and then took time
off from being transportation secretary
don't forget he's our first ever gay
transportation secretary uh in the midst
of our supply chain disaster okay by the
way i'm not taking paternity guys we're
working i don't care if there's kids
down there screaming
we're working through we're playing
through you'll be taking care of the
kids by the way um
but the brain power of kamala and pete
all right these are genuinely the last
people we should be listening to uh but
to close out this segment there was this
other thing on the view from last week
which we couldn't get to because there
were so many other things happening
there was a another woman who who is
actually a conservative uh on the view
her name is kate granger and she was on
talking about i'm sorry lindsey granger
not kate granger her name is lindsey
granger and she was on
uh the view talking to them about guns
and defending the second amendment and
this was in light of the uvalde shooting
and everything else and listen to this
smug response by judy
most ar-15 owners are former military 35
players
so that's all i'm saying
okay here's the thing once black people
get guns in this country the gun laws
will change trust me
god it's
it's so dismissive it's so incredible
the way sunny hostin with the always
looking at her hair you know doing this
with her hair and looking down on people
and the way joy's pointing at the black
woman talking about black people getting
guns uh you guys aren't going to believe
this but i did a little research before
the show sometimes i ask you guys to do
the research i did research before the
show and it turns out that black people
have the same access to guns as white
people incredible i found that out on
google i had no idea uh just absolutely
and you're not going to believe this one
this was complete accident i also found
out it turns out black people can get
ids just as easily as white people
freaking out over there it's nuts
these people are deeply dishonest they
are morons and fools and you might be
wondering why am i talking about them
i'm wondering that myself we're going to
have to think about that but the point
is really the point is that it's the the
the death santas line that's the key to
this thing because it's not about the
stupid things that they say and it's not
about the way they treat each other or
they treat their audience or everything
else it's a way that is about the way
they are going to frame the people who
are competent who are going to fix this
mess and obviously desantis is at the
top of that that's going to be our sort
of through line here what are they going
to do to the competent people who are
getting us out we're on our way out do
you feel it we're on it covet no one
talks about covet anymore i know they're
going to bring back kovetu and monkey
pox although i was told yesterday monkey
box is racist which makes no sense but
not whatever completely bananas huh see
what i did there um
but that's going to be the through line
of the show today is is what are they
going to do to those people and it's
happening right now people are getting
us out of this mess real quick guys
let's talk about upside you know from
cringing at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us where
it hurts don't tell joe he's trying to
help you and it really does hurt that's
why i started using upside upside's an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out with every
purchase i'm earning cash back thanks to
upside it helps me out all the time in
comparison to credit card rewards or
loyalty programs you can earn three
times more cash back with upside you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands upside users earning more
than a million dollars every week that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star rating
on the app store to get started download
the free upside app in the app store or
on google play use my promo code ruben
and get five dollars or more cash back
on your first purchase of ten dollars or
more next claim an offer for whatever
you're buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit card
or debit card and get paid download the
free upside app and use promo code ruben
to get five dollars more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more using promo code ruben and now back
to me
okay
so
death santas that is what sonny hostin
called him that is what joy behar
laughed at the media has tried to scare
you that he's killing old people and he
hates gay people and he's very mean and
he must be a fascist or a dictator or
something like that
but it turns out that he's actually a
pretty decent humble guy and if you
don't believe me this is rather
extraordinary i actually my eyes
actually popped when i saw this
yesterday this is a tweet from kimberly
leonard and she dove into some of ron
desantis's personal finances governor
desantis who is 43 still has over 21 000
in student loans he doesn't trade
individual stocks his net worth is 318
000 far lower than many top politicians
and if he runs for president he may
clock in at the lowest net worth in a
crowded field now first off let me just
say something here
having 300 000 in the bank is pretty
good and especially now even though 300
000
is not nearly what 300 000 was say hey i
don't know a year ago right we know it's
about 10 less
just an actual value because of
inflation thanks to joe biden um but the
point is that in the world of politics
where gavin newsom let's say is worth
100 million dollars nancy pelosi is
worth a hundred million dollars and
they've done this uh thing where they
track nancy pelosi's stocks and she's
always ahead on stocks she always knows
when to dump stocks correctly and when
to buy stocks correctly barack obama
worth 70 million dollars george bush
worth 50 million dollars joe biden who's
been in public service his whole life
about 50 years is worth 20 million
dollars donald trump is worth 3 billion
so ron desantis
right who is in the military uh ron
desantis who has been in public office
right uh he's worth
a paltry amount relative to all of that
do you think he might be doing this
right he still has the 21 thousand
dollars worth of debt for school that
he's paying back um he's not doing this
for money obviously um and this strikes
me as very good it strikes me as very
good and not only does that strike me as
very good what he is doing right here in
florida is very good as you know and
that's why they're going after him uh
and something interesting happened to
florida in just the last couple days
don't take it for me though listen to
ronda sanders no state has ever had that
much of a percentage for
uh for foreign tourism and we usually
are behind new york were
much higher than new york is now and
because we don't let people get harassed
about their vaccine status and mass
so you get it new york usually tops the
nation in tourism can you imagine
someone saying i'm taking my family to
new york we're going to get on the
subway and go to new york i don't say
that with great pleasure actually as
someone from new york as someone that
used to love new york city i mean i'm a
true new yorker i was born in brooklyn i
grew up in long island i had
grandparents and great grandparents
living in new york city i spent most of
my formative years in new york city i
was in new york city for 9 11. uh the
fact that these socialists de blasio and
the new clown that they've got that
they've destroyed the city is not
good it is not it is not something i
take any joy in however
what we've done down here in florida
my new home state
thanks to ron desantis is pretty damn
good and now we're beating new york in
tourism so that's one thing okay you
keep a state open people want to move
here they want to vacation here they
want to spend more time and money here
but of course you guys know it's not
just that uh some of you have seen this
already but during my talk with ron
desantis in orlando about 10 days ago uh
he went on about how he stood up against
the machine stood up against the media
and stood up against the fraudulent
anthony fauci
and the fact is fauci was wrong about a
lot of this stuff okay
we were the first big state to guarantee
every parent the ability to send their
kid to school in person way back in 2020
right
fauci opposed us having kids in school
he opposed what we were doing when we
had businesses open and protecting
people's jobs and were having these
events he opposed us every step of the
way and so that wasn't based on data
because the schooling was obvious that
you needed to have the kids in school it
was based more on ideology
i want you to think that i asked
desantis about this
later in that interview about what it
takes to stand up to the machine because
we all think we would do the right thing
when when the [ __ ] hit the fan right we
all think we would we would be the one
to stand up we all think we would be the
one to go against the mob and all of
those things and most of us never do it
most of us never do it and i would
include myself in that i do take a lot
of unpopular positions i fight for what
i believe but i don't i probably don't
do it at every given moment all the time
right we all have our own concerns he's
got his own family etc etc but think
about that that craziness at the
beginning of kovid and how everybody
just kicked people out of work and fired
people and shut things down and locked
people in their houses and all of those
horrible things and desantis for
whatever reason in him and i asked him
about it where did it come from within
him if you haven't seen it you can see
the full thing right now um
he didn't he didn't go with the crowd
and it turned out to be right he kept
the schools open and did we have mass
death of students and young people here
of course not of course not so sunny
hostin when she calls him death santas
is in she's she's an evil liar that
that's all that you are sonny haas and
you are you are a bad actress an
unpleasant person and an evil liar
that's what they are but they are going
to keep coming after him and why are
they going to keep coming after him
because now he's hitting biden and the
biden thing is crumbling and why is it
mostly crumbling well it's mostly due to
the bad policy it's not even the
dementia right it's not even the the
cognitive stuff it's mostly because the
policies are bad if he was slurring all
his words if he was unable to read the
teleprompter if he was falling down the
stairs and wandering free range out
there on the grass when they let him off
the helicopter and couldn't find the
door if all of that was still happening
if he was taking orders from the easter
bunny all of the stuff that we keep
seeing happening if the country was
basically in good shape nobody would be
complaining and i would be complaining
far less honestly if he was just a sort
of old losing it buffoon it would be
kind of funny but if the country was
working out it's like all right we'll
move on and talk about other things it's
the coupling of both of those things
that is the problem but it's mostly the
fact that the economy
and the energy sector and everything
else is really really struggling and ron
desantis is calling him out on it this
administration seems to not have any
proactive solutions to it other than
blaming putin
they're the cause of a lot of it joe
biden came into office and declared war
on american energy we were energy
independent for the first time in my
life when he came into office he had
sweeping executive orders to try to
kneecap american energy production and
look this is a global market it's not
just the u.s but he has made it way
worse here in this country and they will
not reverse course this is just a
religion for them to be attacking energy
production in the united states and
people are paying at the pump like never
before it's hammering blue-collar people
working people
all right so clear and honest truthful
refreshing to hear so what's happening
well you've got desantis's political
sanity and rationality and that's
coupled with the craziness of the left
so what does that add up to if you take
those two things you put a plus sign
between the two of them and then you put
an equal sign well what do you got you
got a gold mine on the other side for
conservatives for republicans to really
turn this thing around and that's why
i'm feeling good about the world right
now because opportunity is right in
front of us but we have to grab it we
can't just sit there with it so here was
an interesting moment on on cnn anderson
cooper was inter interviewing this guy
harry enton who dives into a lot of
numbers and polling and all that kind of
stuff and they well just take a look
obviously buttons not on the ballot but
uh which party do voters trust more
right now uh uh you know this is this we
might as well call this segment the not
surprise segment uh the republican party
they much more trust the republican
party by 20 points uh 51 i think to 31
you see it on your screen right there on
this is just specifically on inflation
this is specifically on inflation this
is specifically on inflation if you look
at the broader economic spectrum as well
it's basically the same numbers but it's
inflation that is driving these numbers
and driving the numbers on the economy
and driving the negative perceptions
abiding and not surprisingly voters are
running the other way going a democrat
going to republicans i mean obviously
for democrats andy converse and jimmy
carter at this stage for president biden
that's it's not a good great comparison
there okay so what's fascinating about
can see in his body but he's sitting
back he doesn't want to hear this but
they have to acknowledge some level of
reality they can [ __ ] you and they
can lie to their own audience all the
time but then at some level you have to
occasionally release something true so
people don't feel completely gaslit and
insane the entire time but what they're
in essence saying is in these generic
ballots people are realizing the
democrat policies putting aside biden's
cognitive stuff putting aside the woke
stuff and all of that the fundamental
policies the only thing that these
people are really supposed to do
it ain't working and that
is creating an incredible political
refuge for sane people so now let's talk
about some sane people you know about
this elon musk guy the tesla guy the
spacex guy the neurolink guy that guy
well just yesterday he voted for the
first time in his life for a republican
we've got a tweet from the texan
republican myra flores has won the
special election for texas's 34th
congressional district flipping a seat
that has been
under nearly unbroken democratic control
for four
decades now a little more on the
district itself it's an 84
hispanic district
and
it's a border district so do you think
that people who live on the border of
texas and mexico who are watching
immigrants not immigrants illegal
immigrants
not immigrants okay immigrants implies a
level of legality who are watching
asylum seekers or criminals or drug
cartel people et cetera et cetera
come into the country do you think
they've had enough and they know that
it's the biden administration that's
just allowing these people in and
interestingly the media is going to
struggle with this because how can the
media call these people racists because
they're hispanic they're often mexican
themselves
many of them came here legally but why
are they against illegal mexicans coming
so this is fascinating
by the way the woman there flores she
will be the first mexican-born woman
elected into congress and she's a yeah
republican hot diggity dog so how is
this connected to elon well he voted for
her look at this elon musk on the
twitter machine i voted for myra flores
first time i ever voted republican
massive red wave in 2022. now there was
an interesting response to his tweet
there let's jump into that uh tesla
owner silicon valley just a random
twitter account said to him i assume
republican for president two he wrote
tbd but then it goes on a little bit
more
what are you leaning towards and there
it is
desantis
desantis so do you see what's going on
here elon musk is not a traditional
conservative a contr a traditional
republican right whatever the scary idea
of that thing is that you probably are
that i probably am at this point right
but what he is doing is running away
from the lunacy and that's what
everyone's doing and this is going to
leave joe biden and his media cohorts
very alone and once it has imploded
enough the woksters will and i mean the
squad and the people who have used him
the the progressives that have used him
to just infiltrate the system they will
drop him too and everyone will be saying
oh we always knew something was wrong
with him and he was a horrible choice
and the scary part of this is that the
progressives will be saying ah see this
was our last ditch effort to tell you
that capitalism and democracy or the
united states even works we have to go
further to our socialist literacy so the
democrat party is j is gone but the
point is that the conservative camp is
becoming a sane political refuge for
generally apolitical people all elon
musk is saying is
i want to live my life i want to
innovate i want to build businesses all
of those things so it's super super
interesting here he also had another
tweet
about what happened what would happen
and what has happened related to
building a company in say california
versus building a company in say texas
look at this
in texas oh so this is this is tesla
owner silicon valley quoting elon musk
in texas it took us 18 months to build a
gigafactory in california we'd still be
working on the permits and probably
getting sued so what he's referring to
there obviously is that he moved tesla a
year and a half ago roughly out of
california because of high taxes because
of lockdowns all of the crazy insanity
he moved it to texas
and then hot diggity dog what happened
he can start building faster and more
efficiently there are less taxes on him
as a corporation less taxes on his
employees that he brought there now the
hope is that his employees will realize
that
they had to flee a blue state and come
to a red state uh you know i feel that i
should in light of this i should put a
little more money in the in the jar to
get a democrat to leave
florida you know some people are pissed
at me by the way that i changed it and
now it's to get a democrat to leave
florida instead of rescuing a california
so we'll it's still 50 50. i'm not
exactly sure at the end of the year we
will decide and we'll figure it out i
know a lot of people i've met a lot of
people on the on the road who are like
dave i want that cash i got to get out
of cali uh but this is really
interesting stuff and the point is that
this stuff is somewhat apolitical this
is about people taking responsibility
for their lives this is about people
trying to figure out where they want to
live that's more in line with their
values where they're not going to be hit
with
taxes and all of those things and a
little more on what's going on in texas
i know i'm very florida focused here uh
but the texas attorney general ken
paxton is doing some good stuff we've
got a tweet
from the new york times see we even
tried to source the new york times on
this one ken paxton the texas attorney
general is likely to yield political
benefits by investigating twitter
including aligning himself with elon
musk and endearing himself to
conservative voters now in essence what
he is doing is he's investigating
twitter to see if they were
conspiring fraud upon the texans who
were using twitter meaning did you guys
lie about the bots did texans then the
average texan or a business owner in
texan did they put money into twitter
either through stocks or through
advertisements on numbers that were
actually faked so this is what an
attorney general is supposed to do so
this is the states doing the work that
the federal government
perhaps is supposed to do or we thought
was supposed to do however you want to
look at it maybe it's not supposed to do
it at all but the point is we are going
to have an alliance
of
states that operate cleanly and work and
work for the people and then we're going
to have a bunch of blue states that's
pretty much how it's going to happen but
i want to finish up with one other thing
because yesterday on the show we showed
you a clip of uh joe scarborough and joe
scarborough is the morning guy on the
mental institution the televised mental
institution
known as msnbc and uh he's very angry at
joe biden and yesterday
he was thanking joe manchin
now you guys know joe manchin
is the democrat who basically would not
vote for joe biden's huge bailouts it
was one of the things that got all of
the democrats his own party the squad
and everybody else he's a white
supremacist that he's a racist and he's
a trumper and he's a republican all of
those things but anyway joe scarborough
yesterday was basically thanking joe
manchin because his argument was hey if
joe manchin hadn't voted against all of
this byte and stuff all of these the
trillions and trillions of dollars that
they wanted to push then even more money
would have been spent and inflation
would even be worse so we showed you
that clip yesterday and i said live on
the show
i said live on the show you can go back
to the tape i said i bet you we can find
video of him saying completely the
opposite a month or two ago
within two minutes after the show conor
was able to find this we put together
these two clips and this ladies and
gentlemen if you share one thing from
the reuben report with your friends and
family today this is it because it sums
up the absolute farce that is our
mainstream media that is the swamp that
is all of the people who lie to you who
get everything wrong the whole freaking
thing take a look this is pretty simple
stuff let me say that again
this is pretty simple stuff
you get the head of the progressive
caucus
you get joe mansion
and you get
joe biden
and you put him in a room
and you say we're not going to get out
of this room until one of two things
happen
one we have a deal
or two
we're gonna have a press conference
where
we go out and announce that joe manchin
does not support any piece of
legislation regarding build back better
he we either have a bill or joe manchin
will never support anything and he's
been lying to us for the past year and a
half it's very clear my god i just
wonder what would have happened if
progressives have gotten their six
trillion dollar wish earlier this year
yeah in an ironic way you almost have to
thank joe manchin for blocking that i
wouldn't even say ironically thank joe
manchin you can just thank joe manchin
uh if
you're glad that interest rates aren't
even higher
that's conor with the curvier enthusiasm
ending right there but doesn't that sum
up the whole freaking thing
that joe scarborough a couple months ago
on the televised mental institution
known as msnbc was basically
calling joe manchin a traitor basically
saying blame this guy for everything
basically saying the economy is going to
crash if joe biden and the progressives
don't get enough money then they pass
enough of this thing the economy is
crashing right now a recession is coming
inflation is insane
and now
he's realizing it he's seeing the thing
turn right in front of him so now we
better thank joe manchin and not even in
an ironic way ladies and gentlemen that
is the power of the meme so we put that
together it's got about 500 000 views on
twitter already we're going to put it up
as a youtube clip so you can share it
with friends and family because people
need to know this and that isn't to say
you can't get things wrong have i got
things wrong on this show for sure i try
to correct myself when i do but have i
made wrong predictions have i thought
things that are going to happen that
don't happen i thought trump was going
to win the election i mean of course but
like the basic idea of if you don't do
the thing we want and spend an awful lot
of money you're evil and now he's
thanking the guy for not doing it
you can't make it up but nobody gets
fired from these shows nobody gets
called out really well we call them out
so that's all right let's jump to a
couple locals comments before we get to
the cold close patrick says the view is
like a tribute act to the three witches
seen in macbeth oh that's funny that's
funny we should do something with that
speaking of memes that's good man
tollway says desantis is the best
candidate for president if what he does
can translate to the national stage if
that happens dave for press secretary
and tim poole for secretary of the
interior you know he's got a great press
secretary christina pusha she is
absolutely awesome but look if they
called me
i would strongly consider it or do
something i suppose i mean just just so
the losers at msnbc and cnn could be
talking about me all day long and i'd
get up there and i'd have my book of
papers and oh my god what's going on and
they'd have to it just would be
something else
tony says just finished my dmv
registration in florida congratulations
i did it myself a couple weeks ago and i
am now a registered republican myself so
much easier than california florida just
gained another republican today you know
as well congratulations and good for you
and welcome to the free state of florida
and as ron desantis pointed out in my
interview when he came into office there
was a deficit for republicans
phoenix get me on the numbers again i
think it was a deficit
of about 300 000
meaning there were 300 000 more
registered democrats
than republicans in florida they it is
now
a positive a net positive of 170
000 as of yesterday as of yesterday
that's a 470 000 swing in this state man
he is going to crush it and and he
should crush it and we will continue to
live free and speaking of living free
there was a an iguana again in my pool
today and we've got some guys doing work
out here and they tried to grab the
iguana because they were going to skin
it and eat it but the iguana did escape
so i just wanted to give you a quick
iguana update uh if you want to chat
during the show join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and a little a
little teaser for you guys we are
releasing uh the full stand-up lecture
portion of my set uh with ron desantis
it was the culmination of the entire
tour the big the big show in orlando we
are releasing that on friday that will
be free to anyone who is an annual
subscriber to the reuben report locals
community so you can jump over there
right now reubenreport.locals.com
and you will get that absolutely free
whether you're a current member or you
sign up today or you sign up tomorrow or
you sign up in two months
and uh and it's funny and you're gonna
laugh and enjoy it and it's truthful and
decent and comedy ain't dead i promise
you and speaking of comedy for the cold
clothes here's the elderly man
pretending to be president
that's because all the women in my life
are smarter than i am
and i shouldn't have done that because i
wanted to yield to my vice president
who's smarter than i am
my little sister is my best friend in
the whole world
she takes care of me all the time
because the time i've been a child
she's been on my handlebars right here
smarter than i am better
help stacey abram in georgia
there's three things i learned about
early on one she's loyal
two she's capable and three she's
smarter than you me
we have great confidence in our son
i am not concerned about any accusations
but made against him
it's used to get to me
i think it's kind of foul play but look
it is what it is and
he's a grown man he is the smartest man
i know and a lot more going to die
unless he gets a lot smarter a lot
quicker mr president
did you use the word smart don't ever
use the word smart with me don't ever
use that word
you